foreign
go out to Toronto Canada and see if you
can help me Mary help me I don't think I
can
I'm really happy to talk to you though
awesome awesome hey so what's going on
how can I help
it's kind of a two-part question
um how do I explain to my kids about my
financial situation or my lack of money
Financial where I used to be able to say
do things that they wanted to and now I
can't and how do I teach them the value
of money when on the other side their
father spends and my ex-husband spends
money like crazy
um yeah so what happened yo you got
divorced
yeah it was a very bad divorce yeah and
when you found out I had more I had more
custody when he found out that he would
have to pay child support he wanted 50
50 custody just so he wouldn't have to
pay child support and like everything he
does he tries to make sure that he gives
me the least money possible
um so that's like single mom of three
boys so and I am I'm on my farm and it's
not like I have a certain income from
that and it's very busy to say get a
second job
um we're fine but you know I can't do
things like I used to and you know they
always question why and like Dad has
money well how come and Dad spends money
on fun stuff and I have to spend you
know like my extra money on their Sports
and tutoring and not fun stuff yeah I
hate that for you I'm sorry
thanks
um
like we can talk about the money part
but
um and I won't even dig into the other
stuff because that's not what you called
but
I know that hurts
like all of it
and if you yeah yeah it is and if you
look at the data
even in 50 50 custody splits men's net
worth goes up over time
um while Single Mom's net worth goes
down even if it's even if the money's
split and there's several different
theories as to why that happens but
and it may be because Dad gets to buy
fun stuff whenever he wants but mom has
to actually pay for things that the kids
are doing and they actually need and
those things are expensive and they add
up but all I have to say is this I'm
sorry
how old are these boys
um
8 10 and 12. okay so that's perfect so
they're old enough to begin to have some
um
more challenging conversations so here's
a couple of big picture things we're not
gonna do okay
number one we are not going to get into
a comparison game with Dad it's a Fool's
errand there's a reason y'all got
divorced okay yeah
um you don't want to get into that game
so you're gonna have to do the work on
your end
that when they come home and say guess
what Dad bought us guess what Dad got
guess what dad took us that you were
able to Exhale and on behalf of your
boys
say I'm glad my boys got to have a good
time
like I'm glad that they were able to
have this experience because they
clearly had a great time
not gonna I'm you have to practice that
otherwise you're going to be so filled
with bitterness you know what I mean
because it's not about him anymore he is
out of your life
and that's part of the hard part like
there's so much resentment for him as
well that I don't want to have and I
don't want to put that kind of burden on
my boys either I know and the money
question well you you just brought it up
so I'm gonna go there I this is a money
question but this is like a 30 second
money question
this is a you sound as a wife who's an
ex-wife who's hurt very badly is that
true
yeah yeah very
and
I'm gonna tell you please don't let that
resentment and bitterness spill over
into your soul one more second and I
know it's easy for me to say
um
but it's gonna poison you and your ax is
just going to move on down the road
doing whatever stupid stuff he does
and so your resentment and your
bitterness are simply going to serve to
keep your
um tree from growing you're just gonna
poison your own Roots it's not going to
affect him at all if the amount of
bitterness and resentment you held like
hurt him
you could probably convince me that
that's a good idea but it's not it's
just gonna hurt me there okay
um so how do you let go of resentment
how do you practice that I don't know
another way other than making uh then
having a daily journaling or daily
Writing Practice
where you slowly begin to and this is
gonna sound crazy Mary and you're gonna
be like I hate that I called this guy
but yeah you consciously write down once
a day if you can do it twice a day
you're awesome but once a day
I wish him the best
I wish that guy the best
even though you don't do you
are you laughing at me
it's just like I I don't know if I could
write that like I know I know I know
I know I know
you need to write down you you Worthy
you wish him the best no
because this this is
um you're poisoning yourself you keep
drinking it
and I want you to pour it out before you
pour it down your own throat
and so we're going to practice hey Dad
got a new truck and his his new
girlfriend she's incredible she I'm glad
he's doing well
good for him
because what's the alternative hoping it
all fails
because I'm gonna tell you it's already
all failed for him
he's so sick and I know it's not right
and I know like yeah and I kind of do
like because I want my boys to be okay
so like if he's okay like they're okay
that's right
but here's the other deal
um
his life sucks
and he's so stupid he doesn't even see
it yet
and it's like your friend it's like oh
my gosh I just put twenty five thousand
dollars I got 25 000 in an inheritance
and I bought a bunch of Beanie Babies
they're gonna be make us rich and you're
thinking oh no no no no no no what are
you doing right it's that he's so stupid
he blew up his whole life
and he's gonna have sons that when
they're 25 and 30 they don't talk to
their dad
do you think that's gonna happen I know
it's gonna happen
I'm I worked with those boys those men
and there comes a light bulb one day
when they say why did you leave Mom why
did you leave us and by the way how long
is this divorce how long have you all
been splitting 50 50 custody
yeah two years
has it started waning yet
what do you mean oh well like this
winter like I had them more that's right
I can almost guarantee you that over the
next three to five years his time with
them will be less and less because
they're going to start intruding as they
become young men they're going to start
intruding on his good time
and so you are playing I tell everybody
who is gets Divorced with young kids you
instantly go from I want them to have a
good seventh grade year you do still
want that but we are now looking at a 10
to 15 year window
now I want 22 year old men
to never for a second doubt the
character and integrity and love of
their mother
that's the game we're playing now and
it's not a game this is our life but
this this is the shift
and that shift is going to be here's
ways we we teach our kids about love and
connection
you're going to sit down with them and
show them the budget
show them how much money you make
here's how much money we make and here's
how much bills cost here's how much this
cost here's how much this cost here's
how much this cost and this is what we
have left
and some of this goes to savings some of
this goes to giving away and then after
all of that this is what we have
this is why we can't go to the
trampoline park and go camp go good do
all this crazy stuff all the time
and that brought too much of a burden on
them like no it's it's teaching them
you're not shifting the burden to them
you're just saying Hey I want to teach
you guys how to budget and we're going
to do it fun this is how much money we
make in the house
and you can say when your daddy chose to
leave
the court said he had to continue to pay
for your house because he's your dad and
so this is how much money comes in and
my job this is how much money I make at
my job
and I would tell you
you're gonna have to change your
attitude about work for a season
probably
when somebody says hey you may have to
go get a second job or a different job
and you're thinking I can't deal with
any more change I'm so exhausted I can't
even see straight
and you shut down that conversation
which you are shutting down is
five years from now Mary
with a really incredible job and some
kids that are older and they're
teenagers and y'all are having fun you
know are laughing and you've got car
insurance and they've got a vehicle that
they share that everything starts to
shift and right now you don't see it
because you're still in the middle of it
you still hurt you still hate that guy
so much and that rage and frustration
and resentment consume you you have to
let that stuff go
how does that like as I'm saying that
how does that sound I know it sounded
crazy when I told you to write down
every day I wish him well
hope things are going well for him
sounds hard I want like I want to let go
of that
it's hard picturing it happening it is
can I tell you what I think it's hard
here's what I keep doing dumb like
hurtful and mean things
like
when he's when he's still hurting me
over and over how did you how does he
hurt you right now
well there's things like say with the
boys like with their like with their
activities their sports like that's
something that's really important to
them and then he'll be like no he'll
he'll fight me on it
and he'll and he'll like refuse to say
like they play hockey and he was
refusing to he would only pay for hockey
if he was financially capable and then
he went out and bought a camper
motorcycle and whatever else okay but
why in the world I know that's
frustrating but why do you let him into
your heart like that
do you like do you realize like through
the boys through my kids though like I
know he's he's not I I think he's not
hurting you I think he's hurting these
kids
like that move tells me the character of
a man he is
and I'm not gonna give that man one
second of my day
he cashed it out
that's a man who cheats on his wife
that's a man who can't admit to
challenges that's a man who chooses I'm
gonna go do this right now over
my kids really want to play hockey and
they're pretty dang good and actually
there's been enough disconnection in
their life this is a way to to bring us
all back on the same page
yeah it's a child it's a coward
and I'm not going to give that guy one
second of my day so if he gets a camper
you can shake your head and then go on
about your day any choice after that to
dwell on it to think on it to dig into
that is a choice for
it's a choice for you to be miserable
I'm not gonna do that
and yes what I'm asking you to do is
borderline impossible I get that
that's why I go back to say you've got
to write this stuff down I wish him well
I hope the father of my kids is healthy
and whole making good choices and I hope
he's happy
but as for me and my house
I'm gonna be honest to my kids about the
budget I'm going to be honest with our
kids about hey Mom's getting another job
and so I'm not going to be around as
much or we're going to have a babysitter
or I'm getting a new job so I'm gonna
have to do some night school to get some
training so I can go do this new job I'm
going to make a little bit more money
but explain it to him and not in a look
what your dad did to us but in a this is
reality now and my promise to you is
this Mary
when they're 18 when they're 16 when
they're 25 they're going to remember
these conversations these monthly budget
meetings with Mom
and they're going to begin to ask where
was my dad
why did Dad leave us
why was Dad doing all buying campers
since
what in the world
those days will come that Reckoning will
come but again even if it doesn't you
will know and you will sleep well at
night knowing
I was a person of integrity and joy and
peace and patience
all the fruits of the spirit
that's who I am
I'm not going to war with people who
cheat
thank you so much for the call